et on termine ce journal par un sourire
celui d'isabelle adjani et le rôle de
présidente du festival de cannes lui va
très bien
elle se sent en effet très sereine à la
veille de l'ouverture de cette 50e
édition elle l'a confié à richard
treppoz et gilles jacquier et c'est je
crois le moment le plus serein pour moi
à cannes de tous les moments que j'ai
jamais vécue à cannes justement parce
qu'il n'ya pas le suspense du film qu'on
présente la tente des réactions sur
votre propre travail à la c'est un
travail des gens qui sont ensemble
la sérénité d'une star qui lie à 16 ans
montait sur la scène du palais des
festivals pour recevoir à double prix
d'interprétation
d'interprétation pour deux films wartet
de james ivory et possessions d'andré
d'où la fille la sérénité d'une actrice
dont la dernière apparition sur la
croisette remontait à 1994 pour la
présentation de la reine margot de
patrice chéreau une reine dont le regard
coûtera encore cette année dans le
palmarès
lorsque vous regardez un film vous
attachez d'abord à quoi à l'histoire à
la mise en scène aux joues les acteurs
rien pour moi ne devrait se détacher
c'est le film est à lagrasse rien
devrait pas pouvoir détacher les acteurs
la mise en scène de l'écriture de la
lumière lorsque j'ai déjà comme vous a
proposé d'être président s'est dit oui
tout de suite
c'était oui tout de suite après n'ont
longtemps voilà le dernier c'est ça
s'est fait en deux minutes quand quand
il m'a dit écoutez je voudrais il faut
que je sache elle avance parce que cette
année c'est un festival exceptionnel
bien sûr c'est 50e anniversaire et il
nous faut tout préparer l' avance alors
dites moi et je me suis après tout c'est
c'est l'année ou jamais